Let’s use MATLAB to simulate this whole
color imaging process.
To start with I am going to create again a
short hand for the units of nanometers.
I am going to create a spectral region of
interest and I am going to pick a range from
350 nanometers, just above what we can see
at the blue end of the spectrum.
In steps of five nanometers and I am going
to go all the way up to 800 nanometers.
It is just a little bit beyond the visible
end of the spectrum at the red end.
Now I am going to load some data which is
the spectrum of sunlight measured at the surface
of the earth and we use the load spectrum
function I am going to parse in the range
of wavelengths I am interested in and I am
going to ask for data from the file solar
dot dat.
So this has loaded the illumination spectrum
of sunlight into the MATLAB workspace variable
called E and I can plot E against lambda and
have a look at that and there we have the
spectrum wavelength across the bottom and
intensity on the vertical axis.
Now I am going to load the reflectance information
for the famous red brick.
Going to use the load spectrum function again,
parsing the same range of wavelengths and
the data comes from the file called red brick
dot dat.
Now I can display that in another figure,
create figure two and now I am going to plot
R against lambda and here we see the reflectance
profile of the red brick and we can see that
it reflects more red light then it does blue
light.
Now I can compute the luminance of the red
brick, and luminance is the product of the
illuminance E and the reflectance and I use
the dot star operator because what I am going
to do is to multiply every element in E by
the corresponding element in R. E and R we
can see are both 91 by 1 element vectors,
and the product L we can see is also 91 by
1 vector.
Now I can plot illuminance and we can see
it looks like this; so we have the incoming
light, has got this spectrum.
The light that has been reflected off the
red brick has got a different spectrum, it
has reflected more red and it has absorbed
more blue and green.
Now, we are going to load the response of
the human cones, I have also got that information
in a file that is shipped with the toolbox.
Again we parse in the spectral range we are
interested in and we ask for data from the
file cones dot dat.
Now there are three cones, so the cones data
is a matrix that has got 91 rows and three
columns, each column corresponds to one of
the cones.
Column one is the red cone, column two is
the green cone and so on.
I can plot the cone responses; again, I am
going to plot them against lambda and here
we see the three cone responses, see the blue
cone, the green cone and the red cone.
Now what I am going to do is plot the response
of the red cone to this incoming light.
Now what I am going to do is to take the luminance
and I am going to multiply it by the red channel
of the cones response, so I am going to take
all rows in the cone response in column one.
That is the column that contains information
about the red cone and here I have it, this
is the response of the red cone to the incoming
light from the red brick.
The cone responds to the integral of this
function, the area underneath this curve,
and we can see that this curve peaks up to
about 0.18.
Let’s look at what it would be for the green
cone, so I change that number there and now
we see this is the response of the green cone.
The peak is a little bit less, the peak is
now about 0.11; it is not quite high.
It is the area underneath; this curve is the
response of the green cone when looking at
the red brick.
Finally, the response of the blue cone is
given by this and we can see that this is
a fairly low response, the peak value is only
0.005.
Now I can compute a simple numerical approximation
to the area underneath the curve using some
rectangular integration.
Use the MATLAB sum function and I am going
to sum the luminance multiplied by the response
in the first instance.
I am going to do the response of the red cone
and because it is a rectangular integration
I should properly multiply by the wavelength
step size, which is
5 nanometers, and this is the response of
the red cone.
The response of the green cone would be this.
Almost half the value and the response of
the blue cone is this much smaller value,
about one eighth the response of the red cone
to this luminance response.